quand tout sera fini
et comment faire en fait je vais aller
les records en pourboires jihad
l'histoire de reda ben et ismaël trois
jeunes belges aux originaire de
molenbeek partant rejoindre la syrie
sans qu'aucun d'eux n'est lu le coran
un spectacle tragi comique et crée en
2014 par ismaël saïdi pour ces enfants
qui ne devait voir initialement que cinq
représentations
et pourtant la 136e a eu lieu à la
mairie de trappe devant 300 jeunes du
lycée de la plaine 2 nov
vendredi 15 avril il ya vraiment une
rupture identitaire chez ces trois
personnages et c'est ça qu'on parle dans
cette pièce on n'a surtout pas voulu
être mangé mon réalisateur avec ce
spectacle met juste en tout cas de
pouvoir réfléchir cherche à comprendre
comment voilà quelqu'un qui est né ici
en europe et un moment donné qu est ce
qui peut se passer dans votre pour vous
dire je suis allé me tuer allez mourir
en martyr on est dans une guerre sainte
qu'on arrive à vous faire avaler des
choses mais que toutes les trois grandes
religions monothéistes condamne reconnue
d'utilité publique par le ministère de
l'éducation belge la pièce a été
représentée devant plus de 50000
spectateurs dont vingt-cinq mille jeunes
invités par rachid benzine attrape la
représentation scolaire était une
première en france un débat mené par
l'auteur et l'islamologue a suivi le
spectacle pour libérer la parole chez
les lycéens
j'ai l'occasion ici à trappes là où
j'habite 2
harley dans que devant les professeurs
et ensuite une journée avec les élèves
et j'ai senti que cette question du
jihad
la question de l'identité la question de
la construction de la construction la
question même de l'islam pose problème
pourquoi on organise un spectacle comme
ça c'est précisément pour que des élèves
se pose des questions et c'est de
chercher des réponses sur des questions
qui les occupent
l'éducation nationale c'est enseigner
les enseignants savent faire ça mais il
faut aussi que les jeunes puissent
s'interroger dialoguer discuter
le spectacle a remporté l'adhésion
générale des lycéens qui ont pu passer
pour certains des rires aux larmes et la
réflexion quant à elle a pu être
enrichie en classe grâce à un livret
pédagogique créé autour de la pièce